what was it like for you reading the
script for the first time or being told
about the project with you know what I
mean if you could talk about like the
beginnings of it we thought it was like
super super funny so yeah my parents are
always super supportive of me so they
let me do this one and then yeah I had
such a great time of it right is it one
of these things you you've been in a
number of movies now and you've acted
but you've been in a number of projects
how is it how has it changed for you in
like the last few years in terms of how
you get ready for a role or is it still
the same I see myself like a couple
years like before this and I was
definitely a bit more nervous and with
improvising I wasn't really am you know
like aware of like what improvising was
so I was a bit more nervous onset and
before I get scenes but now I know that
you know if you mess up you can just do
it again
that's actually very true is there do
you feel like as an actor do you do you
feel like you have it on the first take
or do you like having like three or four
takes to sort of get it sure what was it
if you don't mind like what were some of
the days making good boys that you like
will remember forever
I will definitely remember that one
paintball scene that was super fun where
I got to shoot the paintballs I was
really harnessing Keanu Reeves in that
in the matrix I was I was really getting
into that and I also really liked um I
think they kind of had the movie but
there was a scene in this jump in this
jungle gym and that was so much fun for
me because on our lunch break me Brady
and Keith we went into the jungle gym
and we were we were playing
hide-and-go-seek tag it was really fun
yeah I would imagine so basically you
paid to be in the movie you were not
paid because you wanted to hang out with
friends no I was almost painting I was
paid to be
you know it was it was it was like it
was fun because like the whole time I
was just playing with my friends I
completely got it um what is it like
making one of the things that I think a
lot of people won't realize is it's
these are long days for you I mean
you're on set for eight nine hours does
it ever do you feel like it does it ever
get to you or you sort of like you're
just excited the whole time quite tiring
because a child doctor can only work for
I think nine or six hours a day I can't
really remember I want to say it's eight
or nine but not as much as an adult
actor can do so they definitely like
make you do like a lot and that's in
that short period of time especially
when like the three main characters are
just boys completely how do you like to
learn I've spoken to a lot of actors and
I'm always fascinated by how people
learn their lines so is it one of these
things where you like to learn all your
stuff before you start filming before
you start filming
do you like learning what you're gonna
film like the night before how do you
like to do basically I'll read the
script over and over again and then my
parents will help me see if I can sort
of like say the whole scenes see they'll
see the whole scene without you know
like making a mistake and once I get it
really good that's good because you know
after you're really good out of scene
that she's like in your memory you just
do it like that
it's it's good so you can focus start to
focus more on the acting part of it
completely I've spoken to a lot of
people that like saying the lines out
loud or they'll walk with someone and
say the lines as they're walking
everyone has a different process so for
you it's just reading the lines god what
has been you've been a number of things
what's been the toughest role for you in
terms of like preparing for a role and
getting ready I would have to say
probably because every day I would be
the makeup trailer for two hours every
morning and you know I told you how an
actor and a child actor can only work
for like six or eight hours and so you
know they had to do it really fast so
and the prosthetics are like really
itchy and stuff and yeah sure did you
take any of the prosthetics home or did
you just burn them no because you can
only use them once right you once you
take them off and use them you can't
really use them again because in order
to take them off you have to rip it
right so they need scissors and stuff so
you can't really use it but I do
actually have when they kind of like do
the face cast so the product the
prosthetics they on your face I do have
like this sculpture of my face in my
room it still kind of creeps me out a
little bit yeah yeah if I'm not mistaken
you filmed this movie at your actual
school that is crazy no one no one no
one has that happened to you so it's
very weird kids in my class actually we
filmed at my school and research too and
kids in my class I remember had to move
their lockers to a different place so we
could use their lockers elves like sorry
guys and yeah it was it was really funny
and I remember I actually also had to
move my locker to UM that it's very
unusual what is it like living in do you
I mean you live in Vancouver and I love
Vancouver it's beautiful what what is
your favorite part of Vancouver and what
is your favorite part of LA I really
really love the mountains I can ski and
snowboard so every time I get a chance I
will either pick skiing or snowboarding
for this day and I just love to go down
the hill and snow as fast as I can it's
really fun
sure what about LA I really like the
amusement parks probably cuz because you
I loved like going roller coasters and
stuff as well so you've been to Six
Flags got it do you like the Harry
Potter ride oh yeah it's great
I just I
I by the way I don't blame you you are
very correct in these uh in enjoying
them what do you have coming up it seems
to me like you're always busy doing
something course so yeah I'm really
excited to see how people people's
reaction to that um I can tell you right
now they're gonna be laughing their bums
off I hope that that's not even a
question so jumping my last thing about
making the movie you you guys had to do
a lot of stuff and what was for you like
the real challenging parts of filming
[Music]
like to cry for me because I don't know
why it's just like I love to laugh like
a lot I know like so I just I just laugh
a lot you know if I'm Allah if I can
laugh you know laughs and this whites
heart dilly you know hold in laughter
and good boys especially because they
throw all these oats at you and it's so
funny blue you actually you guys had to
cry a whole bunch of times in the movie
yeah couple times not really too much
yeah those are those scenes are always
tricky but that's why that's what I
think real acting is or I can sort of
like you know really get into my
character and feel the emotions it seems
like that completely I'm gonna stop
there and I'm gonna say congrats on the
movie thank you so much for giving me
your time